at least once a year i like to bring in
some of my
kevin's famous chili the trick is
to undercook the onions everybody
is going to get to know each other in
the pot
i'm serious about this stuff i'm up the
night before
pressing garlic and dicing whole
tomatoes
i toast my own ancho chilies
it's a recipe passed down from malone's
for generations
it's probably the thing i do best
it's six
okay you are right after this commercial
mr family
you can do this
mr blue man don't tell me my feet snake
you don't even have feet blue man
blue man where your feet at it's home to
late night with
conan o'brien
excuse me this is a page coming through
i'm sorry
let me just let him through
[Music]
here it is
you know my first guest tonight from his
numerous hit movies including president
homeboy and hunky grandmother
or you may know him from his last
appearance on this show when he tried to
stab
me in the face okay gotta go excuse me
please tracy tracy jordan
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know you really want above and
beyond for that guy today i just hope we
get away with it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is going on a little long
don't don't don't do that hands on pants
on
okay sit in the chair buddy sit in the
chair sit down sit don't
sit down
it will spread
a credit card it'll shred
i just got to get to the hospital and
wait there taxi
sir i don't have any money but i need to
get to mount sinai hospital
no problem hop in wow it's like i always
say
white cab drivers are weird
here in the cash cab it's a tv game show
that takes place right here in my taxi
explain the rules you answer trivia
questions for money and a free ride but
if you answer incorrectly
the game is over and you're out of the
cab so for me to be there at the birth
of my daughter
i have to answer trivial questions
despite having going to middle school
in the exxon station yeah you ready to
play
bring it a gift from france to the
united states
the statue of liberty was completed in
what year
come on i don't know that you've got 15
seconds so you're out of the cab
okay i remember going to the statue of
liberty centennial
because that year someone had spread a
rumor that she was going to slip out of
her toga
and i wanted to see some green boobies
and the mets had just won the world
series because that night i was randomly
attacked
by a mets fan that i had through a
bottle at that was 1986
and centennial is a hundred years
because centipede
means having sex with a hundred women i
got it
1886. yes that is correct
weighing up to four tons what type of
mammal is the famous shamu
she is an orca benjamin fyi
they're very difficult to keep in a home
aquarium right again
the lazy susan was invented by thomas
jefferson
i know because i'm a descendant of
thomas jefferson and
lazy susan herself the capital of the
united arab emirates
is abu dhabi i know that because if i go
back there i'll be executed
there are 12 tones in the chromatic
scale i know that because i'm a musical
teacher congratulations we're here tracy
you made it trishy joy
hero husband diabetic slash alcoholic
yes hold on let me unlock it for you am
i pulling it right
just let go okay it's still not opening
stop pulling it i'm trying to pull it
you keep saying pull it out
pulling on it while i'm here
we really don't do a lot of weddings we
actually
don't play in public very often we are
all
really hoping that pam's wedding works
out
this could be a turning point for the
band
wow oh oh my yeah you haven't seen that
since 1983
but then he scores a basket even though
he's not a wolf anymore
we're here with tracy jordan who just
recounted by the way the entire plot of
the movie teen wolf
please hold andy phone call
nope stay there kev i thought we nailed
the whole transfer thing earlier yeah i
wrote it on my hand
but then i washed it it is transfer
extension
and then transfer again okay andy get
ready transfer here we go
extension transfer ah
oh man it is one three four kev
kev come on castle you are murdering the
gnard this is kevin
please hold and i will transfer you
you're bad at this too don't answer that
call just transfer the damn goal
your call is very important to us
[Applause]
my maid died
please keep your voices down mr jordan
is a little hungover
he pulled an uncle harlan parcell last
night minus the wistful jug blowing
i went out with the interns those white
boys are not
kidding around have you ever tasted
scotch
it's terrible and this thing they call
box seats at the rangers game
it's so cold and what is with hypno
tracy
those are roofies so i shouldn't have
taken two of them for my headache
there he is tonight shooters at
blockheads lay at base and meet up with
my brohams at the cornell club
hey you know it bruh man hey
i have no idea what either one of us
just said well he thinks you're going
out again you got to tell him you can i
have a rep to maintain
if i can't keep up with a bunch of wall
street fat boys
uh oh here come the roofies
you can do whatever you want to me
let's go over some of these symptoms of
marijuana use
shall we you tell me who this sounds
like
slow moving inattentive
dull constantly snacking
shows a lack of motivation
hey tracy i hope you know how much we
value you here
at tgs i like to think of this staff as
a family
this is better than the family no one
around here asked me for my damn bone
marrow
well why don't we make this easy on
ourselves and renew your existing
contract
with a three percent increase
okay sorry it took me so long to answer
i was just thinking about how weird it
is that we eat birds
all right we have a deal you see how
easy
negotiating can be when it's not really
about money how is this really not about
money
well obviously you don't need to work
what's that now charles i'm just saying
you made 300 million dollars
last year so there's no financial need
for you to continue with the show
but i never thought of it like that
thank you
i quit goodbye tracy
had he really not put that together
what an awesome party the best wedding
i've ever been to
i got six numbers one more would have
been
a complete telephone number
this was epic my kleenex shoes
were a huge conversation piece but
man my dogs are barking
my feet were so sweaty i can't even feel
the cold
you